monsieur le ministre délégué chargé des
transports il ne se passe pas une
semaine sans que je ne sois interpellé
sur les retards incidents et autres
difficultés d'exploitation que doivent
subir mes administrés lorsqu'ils
décident de prendre les transports en
commun pour tous ces usagers
l'augmentation du Pass Navigo à de 12%
l'année prochaine à un goût amer comment
en effet justifier de payer plus cher un
service dont la qualité diminue à ce
titre je vais vous faire part de ma
reconnaissance d'avoir accordé une aide
exceptionnelle de 200 millions d'euros à
Île-de-France mobilité pour limiter au
maximum cette hausse je veux aussi
dénoncer le chantage on s'est rendu
coupable madame Pécresse qui fuyant ses
responsabilités autant que ces promesses
électorales avaient demandé de faire
porter le chapeau de cette hausse sur le
gouvernement où est le courage politique
quand on réclame toujours plus de
compétences en se défaussant sur l'état
dès que l'on a cramé la caisse où est la
cohérence quand on s'assure contre les
le site public le lundi pour mieux
demander le mardi à l'état de venir
combler ses failles en région cette
hausse du Pass Navigo madame Pécresse en
est la seule et unique responsable et si
elle reste cantonnée à 12% c'est
uniquement grâce à l'état qui a été
Île-de-France mobilité à hauteur de plus
de 2 milliards d'euros en subvention et
prêts pendant la crise sanitaire puis de
nouveau la semaine dernière avec cette
nouvelle aide je n'oublie bien sûr pas
nos territoires qui se partageront une
enveloppe exceptionnelle de 100 millions
d'euros pour soutenir leur réseau de
transport en commun en marge de ces
annonces vous avez monsieur le ministre
actez la mise en place d'une conférence
pour organiser le financement futur des
transports publics dans la lignée des
efforts majeurs consentis depuis 5 ans
pour les transports du quotidien
serait-il possible de savoir quels
seront les lignes directrices du
gouvernement dans ces discussions et de
rassurer nos concitoyens quand on fait
qu'il sera au rendez-vous des ambitions
affichées je vous remercie